Question 5 is a trickier question about loops.
For each of the loops shown below,
your goal is to determine whether or not the loop always finishes
no matter what positive value is initially assigned to "n."
So, for each of the 3 loops, and you can see the loop code shown below,
your goal is to determine that no matter what value is initially assigned to "n" --
whether the loop always finishes--
that would mean for any possible value "n" is initialized as--
as long as it is a positive integer--
the loop will eventually finish.
The second option is that the loop sometimes runs forever,
that there's some value that could be assigned to "n"
that makes the loop run forever--that it never finishes.
And the third choice,
is that it is unknown--and that doesn't mean that it is unknown to you--
that means that it is unknown to anyone in the known universe.
Whether that loop will always finish for all initial values of "n."